hello and welcome to this video high
noon to zero zero seven five okay let's
see what they do in the Petri off here
d4 Queenie - whoa that's a real wonder
they call it barn burner if it's very
exciting it's okay so it takes with the
beep on even I can yeah people sometimes
tell me that oh yeah they can play
Queenie - that is very boring and just
draw and so on
hmm I am not really agreeing to be
honest yes it's not this is not going to
be something where we're quick
checkmates will happen often that's
definitely true but I don't think it's a
huge issue in terms of being able to
play for win for example I really don't
think that this is an issue him there is
still stuff to play form I think it's
more of an issue if you have opening
lines that have many completely forced
draws where you're just like where you
have a perpetual or Ram where they can
repeat moves something something like
that that's much more of an issue like
this is an ending where I'm I have no
problem with trying to play for win
netsim so how to play interesting I
would like to get the pawns on light
squares down for bishops ending I can
basically always do that like I can he
he cannot really prevent me from doing
it interesting G form okay
gain some space
what is he doing them if I play h5o KH v
is the the issue is that he's with King
age three rook g1 he is quite quick down
[Music]
but I can I can actually play f6 and
king of seven I know that this looks
ugly but it's not a big problem I can
always play f5 later and then have a
good pawn structure okay so he is trying
to double on the g4 I get the 95 in the
meantime
night 95s not an idea I just an idea
five is good I mean you see things
happen it's not just a roar anything I
would like to trade one look that's
often the key thing to do what's going
on here 92 and 94 is not really a
problem I still want you to go d5 so
let's do it
okay that looks fine see threatening no
it's not threatening on c7 I've got rook
c8 c3 and in general my idea is to play
Bishop III Bishop b2 if possible this
age for its much more weakness than my
age 5 and the knight on f5 is total kim
yeah it covers g7 everything that is
surprising what is that I don't even see
why that would work at all I mean he
cannot cover d3 and then everything
falls apart
yeah Bishop c7 was strange so black wins
and 27 moves after Queen e2 it's
possible Queen e2 is not a huge problem
really in the in the petrov I mean if
you totally hate to play without Queens
then the Petrova seal is the wrong
opening for you but if you don't mind
that it's it's fine really
yeah some here he surprisingly took with
the b-pawn I mean the system there's the
game kramnik
karana from the candidates where we got
a really sharp position later as well
but that is a thing the better choice
this is a better pawn structure than B
takes yeah so here we are dealing with a
somewhat we were there is an equal
position I think all these moves I think
quite normal
Bishop g5 okay now the evaluation is
going down it started with +1 that was
that was shocking to me I mean how can Y
be +1 in the position like that that's
difficult to believe that that doesn't
work because of Bishop f3 as well okay
i I do I don't see a point yeah this is
a bit annoying or even I mean it seems
to work but it's that depths that I did
not plan so v6 is probably not a good
move something like age six it's not bad
prepared yeah okay he played we should
be 3/5 yeah now I was quite happy to
take and this is just where I think
roughly roughly equal stock g6 Bishop g2
Bishop g7 h4 no h5 yam this is
interesting
oh I made a huge blunder ha I made a
huge blunder I did not see this one and
that is terrible for like ouch ouch ouch
no just a completely overlooked that he
played exactly how I expected him to
play and then I'm fine but I simply
didn't see them coming to b5 okay yeah
this yeah okay route b5 again and this
now is very okay and the engine is
starting to switch to black which is not
a surprise really I'm here I'm just very
fine but he should absolutely never take
on c7 9f oneness the engine smooth ride
f-14 93 yeah that that should still be
reasonable I rather be black here of
course but this is okay it's okay and
this is true straight straight losing
early on this and he's losing just
everything this this this every single
pawn gets lost yeah that was very lucky
in a way because this route b5 move I
completely it we could completely escape
me that means that h5 is a terrible move
and I have
do something else 97 or something which
probably is about it oh yeah okay guys
thanks for watching